[Music]
after angering many users and being
accused of hypocrisy over the gamestop
saga
robin hood has still managed to raise
billions in additional funds to protect
its business from a cash crunch
situation
two sources told forbes the trading app
secured an additional 1 billion dollars
in funding over the weekend
on top of the 1 billion dollars it
raised last week and was in talks to
raise even more
robinhood has since confirmed that it
raised a total of 3.4 billion dollars in
recent days
the big injection of capital is largely
coming from existing investors
and despite its pr challenges robin hood
still hit record download numbers in the
past few days
on january 28th when the app placed
restrictions on buying new shares of
gamestop
amc and others robin hood was downloaded
000 times and account cancellations were
about 11 000 the sources say
on friday january 29th robin hood hit
about 1 million downloads in a single
day
comparatively robin hood's download
numbers for the entire month of december
2020 were around 800 000
per forbes sources robinhood's decision
to limit trading on certain stocks
received harsh criticism across the
board even across the political aisle
the move created a general feeling that
what should be a free market really had
one set of rules for hedge funds
and another set of rules for retail
investors it was also accused of doing
the exact opposite of its mission
statement
to democratize finance the company
claims the move was necessary because it
was running low on cash
robin hood says it typically has to post
collateral for its traders activity
because that activity was so large
concentrated and speculative
its clearinghouses demanded extra
collateral which created a cash crunch
that led to the trading freeze
the battle over gamestop continues
according to e hort dussinowski of
market data firm s3 partners
short interest in gamestop is now 11.20
billion dollars
with almost 58 million shares which
makes up 113
of its tradable shares shares shorted
have declined by just 8
despite the billions that have already
been lost whether robin hood users will
trust the app to live up to its own name
over the long run
remains to be seen